if you're you know young independent
artists watching this what would be some
advice you'd give them as far as you
know taking the advance or
i mean i would say like with the advance
invest it like straight back in yourself
pay some bills but invest it straight
back into the business because at the
end of the day if the music not going
and you ain't got nothing cracking in
the people face and marketing and going
like what that advance mean like you got
a chain and some money and so you know
it means zero you know what i'm saying
so
i would say like from my personal
experience i didn't do it i wish i would
have did it like with that specific play
you know i'm saying it'd probably be a
different situation right now take the
advance and invest it in yourself
marketing and promo um
videos
um digital campaigns like spend it on
that you know what i mean and make the
label open up your budget or you know
how well it's also crazy too because
like once you're on a major label
it seems as if things get everything
gets more expensive
everything is more like myself you go
into the studio
like as an a500 as an independent artist
you go to the studio i mean sure you
could book my studio for 60 bucks an
hour with an engineer right they're
gonna put you at
paramount whatever and then you'll see
the bill on your and you're like wait a
minute how wait what yeah yeah
it's like every even the video p it's
like yo like like like i was saying like
bro you got here doing doing doing you
exactly you know what i'm saying you got
your own video people you got i mean
this is your city you know what i'm
saying so i think a lot of people don't
realize like pay attention to the little
details when they do something like hey
man not every studio session needs to
cost definitely 300 an hour because
before you know it you'll be like uh
they'll send you or you'll audit the
books or ask how much you spent and
they'd be like yeah 1.5 million and
you'd be like what damn where the [ __ ]
where are they
yeah is that how much you spent uh
i spend some money you spend some money